[Music]
my name is niha rajana and i'm an
applied scientist on the personalization
team at amazon
my work involves using customer behavior
data to guide hypothesis driven
experimentation
running a lot of a b tests and
developing highly personalized
recommendation experiences we really try
to understand customer pain points
during
their shopping journey on amazon and
trying to show them relevant products at
the right time hello
play with the site i'm part of central
ict which is responsible for pricing
all the products of amazon worldwide my
name is antonia and i'm a data scientist
at amazon
i'm part of the machine learning
solutions lab team we're partnering up
with customers on all different levels
be it business or
technical level trying to understand
their business and their problems and
challenges they may face
and how we can solve these challenges
with state-of-the-art solutions
in fields of machine learning and
especially deep learning hello
my name is carl morris and i'm a
research scientist with amazon go we
build
optimization models machine learning
models and use artificial intelligence
to try and learn how we can make that
experience a little bit better
i actually have two favorite leadership
principles let me be curious to
constantly keep learning about the state
of the art in research and applying it
to my domain which is recommendation
systems
dive deep because really trying to dig
into customer behavior data
on the website helps us create better
recommendation systems for them
customer obsession is the leadership
principle that i applied
all the time during my job at amazon to
give an example when last year pandemic
came customers were searching for the
items that they needed in the pandemic
and that helped me build the ml models
to prevent
price gouging on such essential items i
love how i get to
improve customers day-to-day experiences
it's really what got me into science in
the beginning is the ability to use my
interest in math and science toward
making the world a little bit of a
better place
the most exciting part about the future
of ai and machine learning is actually
that we have no idea what's going to be
feasible
the future is a great unknown and
thinking outside of the box might sound
silly sometimes
but it might be possible in a couple of
[Music]
years